now without any further to do and since
we've got a lot on the agenda and time
is pressing I'd like to move straight on
to the extraordinary meeting
and I have to start again with a brief
run through
um
good evening I'll start off as if it had
been ordinary good evening members of
The Office of the council and members of
the present public thank you for your
continued attendance at this
extraordinary meeting of the council
I have to go through the filming of the
meeting again I would advise the film it
takes place anyone in attendance in the
public areas may have the image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present does anyone intend to film a
meeting
no any film you're recording will not be
permitted for any item or business or
exempt or confidential information is
considered following exclusion the
present public from the meeting
so with only due a due agenda item one
apologies for absence again I've
received apology from council's Dexter
Moore Rogers towning and Lees councilor
Curry
thank you chair I apologies from
councilor Hopkinton councilor Huxley and
councilor Pat Moore thank you councilor
Curry and councilor Garner I seem to
remember you had as well
well I didn't but I have yes
yes Council of parents
councilor ferent thank you very much
indeed uh yes sir councilor Coleman cook
was a late apology as well great lovely
thanks very much no others gender item
two Declarations of Interest are there
any Declarations of Interest this
evening
No Agenda item three the annual treasury
management review I called upon
counselor David Saunders councilor
Saunders
thank you chairman this has been a long
time coming
this report summarizes a background
backward look on our treasury management
activity for
2021-22 the figures remain provisional
because our 2122 accounts have still not
yet been audited and therefore are
subject to change until the audit is
completed
the regulatory environment places of
responsibility of members for the review
of and scrutiny of Treasury management
policy and activities this report is
therefore important in that respect as
it provides details of the 21 22-year
end position for treasury activities
firstly I'm pleased to report that all
of our activities operated within the
limits agreed by members the other key
messages that I would like to summarize
from a report are
that our capital expenditure was
significantly under budget this is
detailed further in the budget output
report coming to Cabinet later this
month that's on the 20th so not long to
wait
that we repaid 4 million pounds of debt
during the year and undertook no new
borrowing
that our average debt position was 22
million pound and fundamentally we
complied with the requirement not to
borrow more money than we needed to
finance our Capital program as such we
stayed well within our authorized limit
of 96 million pounds the value of their
cash and Investments at the end of the
financial year was 51 million pounds
I moved the recommendations within the
report thank you
thank you councilor Saunders Do you have
a seconder
the leader councilor Ashby I do members
agree
thank you very much indeed now agenda
item four I have a notice of motion
this one notion motion of note has been
received according to the council
procedure rule three please note that
the time allowed for consideration of
emotion shall not exceed 30 minutes
I ask members to be a succinct as
possible
therefore under agenda item for a member
of no sense regarding temporary
accommodation with members please refer
to the supplementary agenda for the
amendment of the notice on motion
regarding the temporary accommodation I
call upon councilor Whitehead councilor
Whitehead
thank you chair
um I'd like to oh sorry was it possible
to pause that for a second briefly sorry
what was that um no I just wanted to say
firstly thank you for not questioning my
needs to remain seated earlier that was
very much appreciated
um and I also wanted to say Obviously it
would be easier for me to remain sitting
at this point so thank you
sorry foreign
thank you chair and good evening Council
I am speaking tonight to introduce a
motion on the continuing and spiraling
need for greater numbers of temporary
housing and thanet and further discuss
the need for growth of our in-house
temporary housing program
to better provide for our residents and
simultaneously reduce the costs related
to using independent providers at a time
when evictions arising and the need for
temporary housing is ever increasing
I have raised this issue many times
before
as Cabinet member I fought very hard to
ensure that our first in-house temporary
housing provision for a house came to be
in the face of what was quite frequently
very intense opposition
I believe in what we can do in terms of
In-House provision
I know our officers and know how much
they care and want to support residents
and want to provide
it was with this in mind that I attended
our budget meetings and Council and
cabinet and overview in scrutiny and
asked repeatedly until you were all
thoroughly bored of me for the majority
of the new homes bonus to be used
towards the purchase of further
temporary accommodation units
I argued that we needed to expand and
that if we didn't inflation would make
it even harder and more expensive to
purchase in the future
at that time I referred mainly to
property inflation as it was then
standing at 19 over the course of a year
now following further demographic
changes and National media articles
referring to the affordable housing that
can be found in planet we are likely to
see even further increases
the argument made then was that we
needed to invest in a larger unit rather
than smaller ones
I understand that argument in terms of
economies of scale
but for the service to grow both are
required and with 91 residents currently
placed out of area according to the last
available figures even two units using
average day lengths would keep eight of
those families an area each year
I know that the inflation I was
concerned about is having an impact on
the plans for a larger unit as I thought
it might
and the more time passes and inflation
increases our chance of delivering what
is needed reduces
added to that the cost of living crisis
we find ourselves in domestic inflation
and the cost of utilities which add
stress to council coffers as well as
huge stress to Residents we are in a
worse situation than I even predicted
back then
we have no clear or firm guarantees on
the renters Reform Bill and although I
hope otherwise I fully expect further
legislative changes to previous
commitments to come in the future
this is a time of extraordinary stress
on residents on services and on offices
I never diminish the realities of any of
those stresses I do try to reduce them
and I strongly believe that the
situation we find ourselves in now is
untenable and unsustainable in relation
to the strain that residents are under
in terms of evictions and outer area
placements that officers are under
trying to support a huge number of
residents and that councilors in many
Wards are under in relation to trying to
support both residents and officers in
finding Solutions
The Perfect Storm I have spoken of for a
very long time now is here and we have
to navigate away through it together
too many discussions and debates on
housing have been unheard in this
chamber recently and regardless of
intent the message that residents
receive is that we aren't listening and
that we don't want to discuss that need
this motion includes all of us it is
inclusive and allows us to show
residence that we are listening and that
we are acting in a visible and public
way
supporting this motion does that
it shows clearly that all of us care and
all of us will do our very best to
address the need that is so very visible
the motion reads as follows
as we are all aware there is a spiraling
housing crisis in thanet and levels of
private sector evictions are increasing
especially within low-income households
in light of this rise in evictions and
the impossibility of finding and
maintaining a private rental property on
the current lha allowance or need for
temporary housing to keep families in
the area is continually growing
as a council we acknowledge and
recognize the need for further temporary
housing units now before further
inflation makes the necessary growth of
our in-house provision impossible an
urge cabinet to bring forward such plans
I ask and urge you to support our
residents and support this motion both
in debate and direct referral to cabinet
since this house Awards convened there
has never been a point of Greater need
thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Whitehead and that was just within the
time limit excellent do you have a
second
I've got several Council Everett you'll
do
what members please note that in
accordance with the council procedure
rule 3.7 if the motion is seconded they
will refer to Cabinet as it relates to a
cabinet function less Council decides to
debate the motion if the council wishes
to debate the motion then follow the
debate the motion will be referred to
Cabinet in accordance with Council
procedure rules 3.8 A4
[Applause]
so far in accordance with Council
procedure 3.7 a would a member of the
controlling political group be is
entitled to make a reply and in this
case councilor Ashby the leader will I'm
sure
sorry chairs councilor Jill bayford it's
her portfolio
the portfolio Holder will in this
instance thank you councilor bayford
thank you chair this cabinet is fully
aware of the issues rated in the emotion
and councilor Whitehead will also know
that from our portfolio meetings that
the housing team are doing everything
they can to ease the situation
I can also say that we are currently
looking at a number of possibilities to
increase our provision of temporal
temporary accommodation
I feel for that reason that it would be
not be beneficial to debate this motion
thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
bayford um can I have a proposal a
second if we wish to debate the motion
councilor Everett would like to propose
who's got is some I got councilor Alban
there thank you do members agree to
debate the motion
I think we better go for a hands display
those in favor of devoting the motion
those against debating the motion
the uh that's lost we're not going to be
debating the motion uh the motion will
therefore be referred to Cabinet Castle
my head
thank you chair um I believe I'm allowed
to sum up in that case
well I think you can be allowed to sum
up yes thank you chair
I would just like to
firstly Express very obvious
disappointment
this isn't the first time that this has
happened when I've tried to discuss
housing I'm certain that it won't be the
last but I had hoped that it today would
be the end of it
there is nothing to be gained within a
council by not debating
affects all of us in terms of reputation
and it affects us individually
as political parties frankly because we
look like we're not willing to talk
and doing this was a chance for
everybody here to be able to show that
this was important and worth talking
about
and every counselor in this room is a
resource all of us have ideas that could
help and would be really useful
I am lucky and that I do have access in
terms of portfolio
I have a chance to put ideas forward
I have a chance to have discussions that
others don't
but there are many councilors here who
are experienced in housing who have
opinions who are affected by it
who would welcome the chance to be able
to talk about it because every time we
try we're shut down
I don't think that's fair to us I don't
think it's fair to Residents and I'm
hugely disappointed that it's happened
again because it didn't need to
and I ask please that this does not
happen again
because we are useful and you should use
us and you should consider how this
looks to residents
thank you
thank you very much
I will slow down a minute I was just
about to congratulate counselor
Whitehead on her strength of opinion
counselor um Everett I'm not I'm not
going to challenge the the way that this
has been conducted or clearly I'm
disappointed by the conservative group's
response but you know we'll deal with
that elsewhere but what I do want to say
is that the discussions we've had
outside this meeting about the handling
of this motion have Illustrated how
grossly inadequate our constitution is
around this issue uh you know we've had
we've had some detailed and intelligent
discussions about it we really need as a
priority to sort out that Constitution
and I'm afraid that what's in that
Constitution about the handling emotions
is just a load of rubbish frankly and
the sooner we get that down the right
councilor Everett
thank you
counselor ever as you are aware we have
already discussed this with the chief
executive and you know there are going
to be some thought about it Council
bayford
yeah I've got to say chairman I'm very
surprised that you allowed councilor
Whitehead to actually wind up on that
because it wasn't a debate it wasn't her
debate wasn't her proposal you know so
at the end of the day
um you know if it had been anybody it
would have been think cancer everywhere
proposed that the debate rather than
councilwise so that's totally wrong
um but what I don't like about it is
clearly the implication here
um when Council over it says it'll deal
with it elsewhere because they now go in
the public and say that the conservative
group don't care about people and
whatever and that is not
can we slow down here the thing about is
we are now having a debate no we're not
right in the debate so that being the
case I've allowed um councilor Whitehead
a few comments and you have your
opportunity for a few comments but let's
keep it at that please it's not a debate
it's a private personal rank chairman
thank you I mean at the end of the day
um you know I think I don't agree with
Council Whitehead I don't think that
debating in this chamber is actually
going to move it forward any further you
know you're totally aware of the no
totally aware of the problems you know
you asked for us to move very quickly on
providing uh you know alternative
accommodation emergency accommodation
and you know it can't be done quickly
you know in such a way I mean you know
I'm I'm sure you'll I know you're very
sincere about the whole matter but so
agree on this side and the fact is that
you know I get a bit fed up with the
fact that
um you know because we're not debating
something we're not doing anything
because that just isn't the case and
personally I don't see how the debate
would actually move it forward so thank
you well done thank you very much thank
you very much um councilor bayford now
the thing about this is we are not
launching into a bait we've decided not
I do feel that as chairman I showed a
little bit of
uh latitude in allowing councilor
Whitehead to come back and I see no harm
in that I am now going to close the
meeting this is not a debate and we
conclude the business of the meeting
this evening thank